well we showed you a clip of his movie a
few minutes ago about a family adventure
comedy following the story of a dad who
takes his eager young daughter on a road
trip to make her spring break special
one that he can't exactly afford and Rob
Schneider joins us live now to talk
about the movie that he not only stars
in but also directed and produced Rob
how's it going thank you Jillian thank
you so much for having me it's great
it's a it's a dream to get a movie on
the big screen and it's a nice little
movie and you know truthfully Jillian
this is the only movie my wife has ever
allowed my kids to go see so I they
haven't been able to see any of the
other movies I've ever made so I had to
make at least one so this one's it you
had to make one well congratulations for
getting it off the ground and this is a
fan Family Affair tell us about everyone
that's in the movie it's quite the list
well my wife Patricia wrote it with me
and Jamie Lisa Omar our good family
friend and then it took a few years by
the time we got ready to make it my
daughter Miranda was uh old enough to
play the lead and so she kept going
who's going to play that what are you
guys working on I'd like to do that so
and she was great she's just a natural
she grew up around it you know she was
like one and we were doing real Rob on
Netflix and then four when we did season
two and so she just uh she grew up with
it just like my older daughter l king
she just it was around it and it came
out great and this really sweet scenes
in this movie that are really nice and
you know basically they can't afford to
go any place because he's broke and he's
a kind of a loser inventor and so
instead of taking them instead of taking
her to a water park he takes her to a
car wash stuff like that you know so we
had a good time making it and we made it
out in Arizona and it just it's going to
be playing it's playing in Select
theaters and one of them is that Las
Vegas at Cinemark yeah we're so excited
to have it here in Vegas and in the
trailer you hear the word Buble but is
it true that Michael Buble makes a
little cameo in the movie
I can't give away the ending but yes
and I just got off
that's funny but he showed the movie to
his dad and uh when when when Michael
was first starting out they wanted him
to change his name was blue blade they
thought I don't know if people are going
to like Buble's I love that name and
he's my favorite singer and uh he's
become a dear friend and um his Show's
fantastic when he comes to Vegas you
guys got to catch it and he's great we
have his music in the movie and we ended
up paying him a lot of money after all
because it's a small movie but the
music's very expensive and it really is
he's a sweet guy in the it came out
great so I you'll have a good laugh it's
the classic of the movies I made with
Adam Sandler this is it's very much down
that same vein and good physical comedy
with the big heart and I hope people go
see it it's opening this weekend in
Vegas so please go out and check it out
yes well we can't wait to see it it
looks so funny and just great to see the
whole family together and before we go
You Gotta Give me a you can do it
you can do it oh Las Vegas Mal how you
made my day thank you rob we can't wait
to see the movie well you can see daddy
daughter trip in theaters now it's
actually at the Sam's Town Movie Theater
right here in Vegas Mercedes